all right Maddie
Maddie uh where are you from originally
where'd you grow up uh I'm from
Philadelphia Philly and uh tell me about
your family
um how'd you grow up
I grew up more in the like suburbs of
Philadelphia so I actually I feel like I
had a very like I was a bit like I was a
very good
very well-behaved kid like I
went to school and came home and did my
homework and
just lived with lived with my mom and my
sister and that was just us gals normal
childhood yeah I mean yes as normal as
as normal as it can be yeah no crazy
abuse or anything like that
um
well it depends what you mean by like
crazy abuse but yeah there was on the uh
on the other side of my family there was
very significant emotional abuse like
mental and emotional abuse so
um yeah there was a lot of
trying to extract ourselves from that
but uh from your father's side
yeah what kind of girl were you in high
school what kind of girl were you in
high school
um
I think I was sort of in like in kind of
like a middle crowd where like
there was sort of the
like The Jock crowd that you know
was a little like you know more party or
but popular whatever that means
um but I I had really wonderful friends
and a wonderful group of friends in in
high school and
um my school was kindergarten through
12th grade so a lot of them I knew
from kindergarten through through 12th
grade so it was we like all grew up
together and
um and three of them are still my
closest girlfriends in the entire world
so she's very lucky in that in that
respect yeah
and uh
you went to college or I did yeah yeah
what did you want to do
um I was a I went to college out here
actually so am I allowed to say where
sure um yeah I went to USC
um and I majored in
psychology and gender studies which is
just a fancy way of saying I'm gay and
have mental illness
but I mean it was great and
um I it gave me a lot of different types
of career paths and career options which
is wonderful but what I ended up
gravitating towards was like psychology
and media and psychology and sexuality
and so I ended up in working in
entertainment so cool yeah so you're
you're in a unique relationship I am
yeah where you are
the sub to someone who is a Dom yes
tell me about that how'd that come about
huh
um
it was a
for me it was a very interesting
really hate to use the word
Journey but
um
I never had a any issue
with my sexuality insofar as you know
being
queer bisexual
little while a lesbian retired lesbian
now
um I you know that was never an issue
for me
um and it was always something that I
felt very peaceful about
um but something that I
realized in I think I realized in
college
um but I didn't really have the
education vocabulary communication for
it even for myself let alone for
partners
um was that I'm wired as non-monogamous
I'm wired as
um gravitating more towards
Kink Dynamics and kink type
relationships
um and that I think was those two parts
of my
I think you know some people choose it
as a lifestyle and others very much
identify it as part of their
wiring it's part of their sexuality it's
part of their identity and for me that's
very much the case
um it's just how I'm wired and
so I think I was I didn't realize it at
the time but I was very afraid of that
and I
I shut that down for a really long time
um about 10 years and
what I didn't realize about trying to
shut one thing down about yourself is
that eventually you start shutting
everything down about yourself and so I
um maybe two years ago I think I was
just in a place where I couldn't figure
it out my therapist couldn't figure it
out you know like why I felt like I
I didn't exist and I felt I felt like I
wasn't a I wasn't a person and it was it
ended up being because I wasn't allowing
myself to be a person and I wasn't
allowing myself to be
everything that I am and there was one
day
it was
I I have no idea where I was I have no
idea what I was doing but there was one
day where everything
where I woke up
and everything I felt like I was hit by
a truck and
I
I woke up to everything that I had been
shutting out
for
years and I knew very clearly
what I wanted and what I needed and that
what was lacking from
my life and my identity and what was
like who I really was and
that led me to
um
to more cank and non-monogamy spaces
um I got on I made a FetLife account
just to
sort of figure out what was going on
with me
um
and
makes them you know just connect with
some people and I found some amazing
friends on there who are still some of
my closest closest friends and we were
able to talk about
all the ways that
Kink is an enhancement to
every area of your life not just
you're not just you know exploring or
you know some people do but
for me it's not just oh I'm exploring in
you know a bedroom or a dungeon or
something like that it it's
across all areas of my life that it's
very important and part of my identity
um and extremely important for my mental
health I mean it's helped it's helped my
mental health
and my self-image more than
anything anything ever
and through
FetLife I was able to explore who I was
and talk to other people and sort of
find commonalities or just learn
different things and
um I've met a really really incredible
people on there including
um my dom who I've been with for uh just
over a year and a half
so you're a submissive yes how did that
how do you think that came about I mean
was there something in your childhood
was it something just genetic that
you're wired this way
um both I think both I think it's
absolutely I'm very genetically wired
that way
um but I make some jokes with my friends
that you know
do you have a good relationship with
both of your parents or do you have a
praise tank now
so uh very much that
um and I got this sort of the cosmic
double whammy of being both a Capricorn
and
the oldest daughter uh or the oldest
sibling and so
um there was very much a
stoicism that I had to maintain and a
strength that I had to maintain and
there were a lot of walls that I had to
keep up just to
get through it and sort of be the
strength
of my little family where I felt that
others couldn't quite hold us up and so
being as submissive has
allowed me to let those down
and to let in
um
a certain type of care that I think I
was very afraid to accept from anybody
else
um before now and
it's it's a lot easier to accept care
in a for me it there's it's a lot easier
to accept care within a dynamic because
I think outside of it maybe you feel
maybe people feel some guilt or
you know oh I should be reciprocating
right now or I should be doing something
for you right now and within a dynamic
that's inherently part of it because
as a submissive that's my role is to
accept
the care
from my dom and that is his role he has
chosen his role that is
something that he wants to give so I
don't have to do
you know I don't have to reciprocate or
I don't have to perform in a way
that I feel is
you know I guess we're like reciprocal
or owed because it's inherently part of
it that he is when you say care from
your Dom what does that look like
um
for me and it can mean very different
things for different people but for me
um it can be anything from
uh I mean first and foremost praise Kink
hi so I will I will accept all of the
praise all the time it's very difficult
for me to let in but I will accept it
and
there's a
there's something that happens in my
brain when I'm told that I'm a good girl
and
that just sort of settles me so I accept
that and then also
from so from that side of things and
then also one of my main
Kinks I guess you would call it or areas
of
therapeutic areas really is impact play
and so
that feels
caring to me being being gifted that
from him
so
this is like being hit being spanked
yeah
um started out with
uh being spanked and then we've moved
into
um using different different tools or
toys or
things like that so
the first that comes to mind because I
hate love it so much is like we've used
a paddle and
um riding crops and
pretty sure a vlogger one time I was
blindfolded and I'm not sure so but you
end up with some bruises and yes and
yeah
um probably blood even a little bit you
know we're not
um we don't go into like full blood play
but
one thing that I really love is when he
will use a knife on me and so it's not
I'm not bleeding but obviously there are
like scratches and and things like that
and I really love that and that's one
thing that I've
found
to be so
rewarding and
um
very like life-changing for my
self-image is I have
well first of all I've never liked I've
never liked myself and I've also never
liked my body I've never been
comfortable with my body
I I don't like it and I don't even
see the like why should I treat my body
well
mm-hmm
um
and
I you know I've just never I've never
felt that I've never felt connected to
my my body I've never felt at home in my
body and
receiving marks from sessions is the
first time that I've ever felt beautiful
it's the first time that I've ever felt
at home in myself and it's the first
time that I've been able to look at
myself in the mirror and say oh
oh there I am
there I am okay it
imagine it might balance out
some of that strength and backbone that
you have to be
publicly yeah or in your family or at
work or whatever yeah
in this privately kind of
balances it out yes is that good word
yeah I think so yeah and it's very
um it's very centering it's very calming
and it can quiet my brain in a way that
nothing else nothing else does
um and one thing I spoke with about my
or spoke with to my friends quite a bit
is
um
I have ADHD and I have a very very loud
brain all the time and it sort of sounds
like
um it sort of sounds like when you're
driving and you're sort of between
like radio zones so you've got one radio
station and it's sort of picking up
things from different radio stations and
then there's also just static and so
you've got these all of these trying to
happen at once and that's sort of what
my brain sounds like all the time
um it's very loud and it's exhausting
um but especially
in submission
all of that goes very quiet
put your teeth yeah
and I
I usually have to you know if I'm doing
things around the house or if I'm doing
things at work I have to have like
you know a show on in the background or
music on or something to like you know
okay I can listen to that so I don't
have to listen to my head and
when I'm in a submissive headspace I
don't need it
I have never needed it I don't need it
and I can
be very very peaceful and quiet
and it's it's very very centering and
it's just so nice
to have that peace
and it's really a it's really a gift
absolutely I see I see my submission and
being
allowed to submit to my dom is a gift
that he gives me and that I give myself
your Dom is your boyfriend no
um actually no um we are at this point
we're very very close we have a very
intimate friendship an intimate
relationship but
um no he's not he is actually married
and I'm
we've gotten extraordinarily lucky
um that I am extremely close friends
with his wife now and I spend a lot of
time with them
outside of any Dynamic play
um and we've we've gotten we just all
three of us have a very intimate
friendship intimate relationship and
it's it's worked really beautifully for
everybody and I think has been
uniquely enhancing
for everyone individually and also which
is very important to me it's enhancing
for their marriage as well and that's
something that I check in with both of
them but I actually check in with my
Dom's wife frequently just to
make sure that everything feels
transparent and open and
she feels comfortable with everything
and it's really really special she's
she's absolutely one of my closest
friends in the entire world
I would imagine that great communication
is is like a an absolute requirement in
this yes that it's
if there's any one
Universal rule for
I mean King play or any kind of for Life
yes exactly but especially within Kink
and especially within any kind of any
form of non-monogamy
people can do it a million different
ways but the one universal
truth is that you have to be a good
communicator you have to and it's
that is what is going to
make for a successful Dynamic
relationship however you choose to move
forward with it but it applies to
everything in life absolutely not just
fetishes and things yes absolutely and
that's and one thing that
um
I'm I'm not very good at but my dom is
helping me and he'll sort of do a
you will gently push me into being a
better Communicator Within
within the scope of saying this is what
I want
um
because I think growing up I was not
really encouraged to have
wants outside of the image that certain
family members wanted to hold for me and
anything outside of that
was way too much way too much and so I
was just okay
my survival mode was okay fine
don't do that
and just be who they need you to be
and just get through it and so now I
it's it's difficult to have wants
because they I get very choked they stop
here
and they the words won't come out
so especially if it's a more
emotional
want
I can't it doesn't come out
um
and it has really really helped to
practice
that kind of communication in a safe
container
within a dynamic or just Within
our
relationship that we have with each
other just to say this is what I really
want this is what I want to try and this
is extraordinarily vulnerable for me and
to create that safety
involves a ton of communication and
building a ton of trust but
being able to communicate the deepest
and most vulnerable parts of yourself to
someone
and have that
not only be
you know a received but
enthusiastically received and someone's
excited to hear that part of you so the
difference that I've found
in my like Kink relationships whether
they're friendships or my Dynamic with
my dom
is that people don't like me
in spite of these things so you know
they're they don't say like oh well
you're a great person and you know you
sort of like that and we'll sort of
ignore that but they like me because of
those things and everything else about
me just sort of supports the fact that
I'm
I'm worthy of
that kind of
love that's not coming with conditions
of well as long as you do this and as
long as you adhere to this and as long
as you're doing this
we start at what I thought was the most
unlovable parts of myself and then go
from there
and so having people say like no no
that's really special and we love that
about you
um
has created a different type of
relationship standard and I use that in
a broad term for friendships for
anything now that that's where I need to
start with people and it's raised my
self-image and the respect that I have
for myself as well
I love hearing that it's like I don't
think you could achieve that with any
pill or any even therapy probably
yeah
I've tried a lot of pills tried a lot of
therapy and I still have those and
they're lovely My Little Helpers and I
adore my therapist and what was a huge
game changer actually was changing
um
switching therapists to a therapist who
is
um
a sexuality specialist not only Kink
aware but extremely Kink informed
um and her like that is her specialty
and she specializes in
maybe your non-traditional relationships
or non-traditional sexualities and
things like that and that was a huge
game changer because I can go into
therapy or with any of my friendships
now and I don't feel like I already have
to justify or reassure anybody
about anything you know I can just start
with well yeah this happened and I
really loved it and not have someone be
like
you did
yeah and I just have that being greeted
with like received and greeted with oh
that's awesome tell me more
and I that has really helped
in my own self-acceptance and also in
what I will
and will not accept from others so it's
like you found a secret
to
to find your own like self-acceptance
and and self-worth even yes
I
did it
um
yeah yeah and I think it was something
that was missing for a very long time
um
and you know part of that was just not
being aware of
all of it and learning more about
kink in general and people in the
lifestyle and non-monogamy in general
for myself
um
but yeah it has been
extraordinarily freeing
and I I say this to people a lot that
you know what I'm in a dynamic where we
do use
terms like ownership and I am
owned and colored by my dom
but in that I've never felt
more strength or freedom in myself ever
and just for the for people that are not
inexperienced with this this is only for
these get-togethers that you have with
your Dom yes this isn't that throughout
your day or anything like that right
you're not you're not a full-time slave
or anything no no so we don't we do not
have a Master Slave Dynamic that's a
that has different
um
components to it and is more like 24 7
and you know similar but yeah there
there's definitely overlaps and
similarities like I am for me it's not
it's not not 24 7 in that
I am a sub all the time I am his sub all
the time
so you know even if we're you know all
hanging out having dinner totally
outside you're not living with him no no
um
but if if we're all having dinner and
we're sitting down and I start to get a
little bit
you know I'm doing a little Jabs and
sort of testing my limits there he knows
that he can give me a look
and I will behave
does he behave the same way with his
wife uh no they do not they don't have a
DS Dynamic no interesting what would you
what would you say to someone who
is is you know just vanilla as you call
it
and is listening to this going oh hell
no I'm not gonna get I'm not gonna let
some guy hit me beat me flog me whatever
that's you know just yeah that's sick
and twisted what would you say to that
that's abuse
well yeah and there are
I mean first of all if that's not if
that's not your thing it does not have
to be your thing so
that's nice for you
um
but
it is really it is everything is
consensual that's a huge part that's a
huge part of how I approach
everything and a foundational aspect of
my Dynamic everything is consensual
um and I had a friend say you know I
think I would have trouble watching a
session where
you know a
you know he's a very tall and strong man
where he is
doing that to a woman like I would have
trouble watching that and I said I yeah
I absolutely understand that that I
would probably I think at the very
beginning I had trouble with that too
even it even though it's what I wanted
I had trouble seeing it
but
what's in what's very reassuring for me
is that everything
everything is consensual we have safe
words and he checks in on me
multiple times throughout a session if
he feels like I'm being pushed too much
or if I'm I'm pushing myself too much
um
and everything is completely and
enthusiastically consensual and in those
moments where I might look like I am
being
overpowered
I have never felt
more powerful in my life
so it's interesting yeah and I I do know
you know there are different things for
different people but I am careful with
who I share
the extent of our sessions or my
experience with people
um just because you know there are some
people who would see
bruises or knife marks on someone and
say
do we need to call somebody for you
and there are other people who go those
are so beautiful
and I have friends where you know we'll
like well a bruise will start to form
somewhere and I'll have a friend say
like I can't wait to see how that blooms
for you
and I love that
because I can't wait either because it
like there's a change in colors and your
skin changes and you just see these
things in yourself that you're like oh
I really am
something else
which I which I really love and it's not
it's not for everybody it's certainly
not for everybody
and I would say that starting at a
communication
standpoint but everything is that's why
communication I think is so important
because there are a million forms that
this can take yes yes what you're
describing is a pretty standard one
actually yeah
um I wouldn't say that we go to
what some might call extremes
um I'm just personally I'm not a
latex or really intense leather person
um
I love an ice collar and
that's all that very much like that but
that's not really where I gravitate
and
so I think you know
outwardly it looks
sort of like
anything else
um
it's just a little spicier how often do
you engage in this
um more frequently now I actually
um I moved a few months ago and because
the universe has a sense of humor I
ended up in an apartment that is about
four minutes away from
um my dom and his wife's house so how
convenient yeah yeah it's so convenient
it's very convenient
um so I'm I mean I just go over there to
hang out with them a lot and they've
they've come over I accidentally adopted
a cat so they they've been over several
times to meet them meet my son and
um
he's a it's it's really fun and so I I
would say
you know we will have some kind of
session
um once a week maybe twice a week the
two of you or the three of you
um the two of us
um
what's really
important for hour and by hour I mean
all three of our Communications is that
um
everything is completely transparent
with
um between me and my Dom's wife first of
all and so
she has always been involved to a
certain extent because her even though
she's not necessarily within like the
Kink lifestyle in terms of impact play
or things like that
um what makes her feel empowered is
being asked
for a session with him and being thanked
afterward and so she has always been
involved
to that extent
um from the very beginning and that is
that is something that makes her feel
really good and that is empowering for
her personally and enhancing for their
relationship with one another as well
that's a good example of how Different
Strokes are different folks yeah yeah
yeah and you know that I think there
again you people approach it very
different ways but that was something
that was said from from the outset when
um my I met my dom and we met on on fat
life and so
that was in within maybe three masses
well in his first message she said you
know I'm married and this is kind of who
I am and
um
I said that sounds fantastic and so that
was always something that I was excited
to do with her I think the both of us
just got the
incredible Stroke of Luck bonus that we
get along extraordinarily well and we
just like hanging out together so we all
three of us got very very lucky in that
respect and one thing my dom said to
both her and I individually was
yeah you guys are you guys are very
similar you're going to get along I'm
I'm making a huge mistake
I'm gonna I'm making a mistake and so we
do laugh about that to this day where
the two of us will sort of get on our
schemes like you
listen you knew this you knew this it's
too late now
it's too late so does this uh
Arrangement have implications in your
romantic life your your love life
does he get in the way of that or does
it no
um no it does not get in the way of that
um
first and foremost they are very
supportive
of me
if I wanted to look for that just to be
clear you are having sex with your
dominant yes okay yeah so does does the
fact that you are having sex with
Adam
effect if you like let's say you met a
guy at work today and
he liked you and you're like yeah like
kind of
pursue this or or just not waste that
time and go back to your Dom next
weekend
um
so it's it's interesting so I
um I was in a very long-term
relationship a very serious relationship
um
that uh ended about just over a year and
a half ago and so for me
romantic dating is a slower
I'm taking my time with it so
if something feels exciting and right
um but it's certainly not something that
I am
chasing after right now
um but that being said you know if if
something romantic came up for me they
would be the first two people who would
be excited and encouraging of that for
me and because they want they want that
for me just as I want that for for their
marriage and for them
um
one thing moving forward that I know is
that I will not have any
relationships that are not
monogamy is not in my future
so
any connections that I make romantic or
otherwise
I make it very clear from the outset you
know and I have
I have dating profiles that I never go
on because it's overwhelming and there's
too many people
um but I have in my profile that I have
a Dom and it's a dynamic that I value
and prioritize and
so I I'm very upfront with that with
people and so
those who want to be in my life
that I could that's what I come with and
over the last
year and a half two years I've
I've had to reevaluate
most of my
friendships and relationships and those
who I've kept very close to me
are my
non-negotiables
because they are
they've literally kept me alive
um
and they've been an extraordinary
support to me
so
moving forward
I come with that
and
I think
those things don't make me any less
lovable and they don't make me any less
able to
love someone
in fact it helps me it helps me love
someone because I know that they know
and love that about me
and they are
happy for me that I have that
may I ask how old you are
I oh gosh
I feel like with the past few years you
just sort of were like I don't I don't
know I am 32. me too yeah do you wish
you had discovered this earlier in your
life
yes and yes and no yes because I do feel
sad for myself that for whatever reason
conscious or unconscious I
shut it down for such a long time
um
but know in that I don't think I would
have been
able to handle all of it very well
in my 20s I don't think I would have had
I know I would not have had the
communication skills and
I think I
um
I think that would have complicated
things in a way that I wouldn't have had
time to really confront what
jealousy means for me
and pardon me
um
I've been able to look at jealousy
differently where I don't feel it as
kind of like a boiling
eating at me sort of way I it's it's
something that lets me know that I am
feeling an insecurity
and if it's just an insecurity Within
Myself
okay I can address that and figure that
out if it's an insecurity within a
partnership
I can communicate that to a partner and
say you know I'm feeling insecure in
this way
and I need support I did not have that
then and I would not have been able to
communicate that well at all
um
so yes and no
but I'm
I'm just happy that I have it now
this has been
one of the most important
the worst word in the world this has
been one of the most important Journeys
that I've ever been on
ever and
being gifted the freedom with my dom too
be everything that I want to be or want
to try all of that is
held safely
which is lovely
thank you so much for
sharing your experiences with this thank
you hopefully it's helpful to somebody I
hope so something's been helpful for you
yeah yeah I would I'm biased but highly
recommend if it's of Interest no it's
great to hear yeah thank you very much
thank you